tonight new information about a crash
involving 10 people over the weekend
thanks for joining us here at six i'm
denise valdez and i'm brian loftis of
the 10 people involved a woman is dead
and several others in the hospital
tonight this happened on charleston on
i-15 sunday as kate houston reports many
involved in the crash were visiting las
vegas
the crash happened here around 1 30 on
sunday morning nhp says a suburban was
exiting the 15 off ramp when a ford
explorer ran a red light and hit the suv
this caused the suburban to flip and hit
a light pole inside the suburban seven
passengers and the driver all were
rushed to umc 54-year-old gina artzer
from shawnee kansas died from her
injuries since word of this crash
happened there has been an outpouring of
support from family and friends on
social media remembering artsar and
prayers for those hurt the daughter of
one injured passenger says the group was
in town for a weekend getaway she says
her mother is intubated and underwent
surgery monday friends posted to
facebook stating they've started a venmo
account to fly the family members to las
vegas and to support the victims of the
crash they know most of their friends
are still hospitalized and have a long
recovery ahead nhp says a man and woman
were in the suv that ran the red light
both were taken to umc it's not known if
impairment was a factor in this crash i
have spoken to a umc representative who
says that the families would like their
privacy right now reporting near i-15 in
charleston kate houston live local now